you if your man was making like very
good money like really good and he told
like okay I'm gonna cheat not cheap not
even just sex with other women what
you're doing like good money
like he's very comfortable you're very
he's looking after you times
how old am I
[Music]
I feel like at 45 I'm like you know what
at this point what am I gonna do right
now right now right are you married
you've been you know do you have a kid
yes I've had a kid I'd be so irritated
I'd be like you didn't tell me this
before I had the child I've had a kid
had sex it's just not about you anymore
but I would leave if I didn't have a kid
because in my head like I don't know I
just I'm big on family and I think it
was really good growing up that I my
parents just were like they only have
dated each other like they're the only
significant other both of them have had
and I think that's just like better